so in the greek times people were very
interested in regular polygons and in
geometry with the dawn of geometry
really and they wanted to construct as
many polygons as they could but regular
all the sides all the same length all
the angles the same they were very
interested in constructions with ruler
and compass alone here's a good compass
ruler meant just a straight edge no
markings on it roll this one has
markings but i'm going to use it anyway
i won't use the markings here's a nice
circle
drawn with a compass and the old style
so if i pick a point on the circle i'm
going to draw a hexagon
in a way that everybody will know who's
ever played around with ruler and
compass i'm keeping the compass length
the same as it was
for the
original circle whoops ran out of ink
there
here we are but the ink is so satisfying
to me
that i don't mind the splotches
occasionally
all the circles pass very nicely through
the center showing that i haven't
changed the width of the compass and now
i have six marked points on the
circumference of the circle
and if i want to i can put lines through
them
and i'll get a beautiful regular hexagon
make the lines a little longer it's even
nicer
ruler and compass constructions are
something else
there we are beautiful hexagon and of
course if i just connected three of the
points like these three i would get a
regular triangle if i have any line i
can divide it in half with ruler and
compass alone i think that's worth doing
just to show how it's done i'm going to
use it a lot later so suppose i have a
line and suppose i have a couple of
points that were already marked on it
and i want to construct the midpoint of
that segment and a perpendicular line
through the midpoint i can do that with
my
ruler and compass and i make some pieces
of a circle
on each side
and i look at the places where this
circle meets them and then if i connect
those two points those two new marked
points i get a perfect
perpendicular bisector of this segment
so the the ancients knew how to do
a
triangle and a hexagon the way i did it
they knew how to do a square because you
can make these perpendicular lines and
that makes it easy to do squares
they knew how to do a pentagon that's a
little more complicated
and that's all they knew they could put
3 and 5 together to get a 15 gotten too
but for instance
you know what's the next number we know
how to do three four five six
seven right can you do seven no one
could say and they asked can we do this
is it possible to construct a seven gun
or a nine gun or anything else anything
else at all other than
the ones you can get by taking three
or five or three times five or dividing
those things by two you can divide again
and again by two just the way i did here
to get like a thirty gallon or a 60 gun
that's all easy once you have a 15 gun
it was an open problem from antiquity
for two for 2 000 years people played
with the ruler encompass and worried
about that and then something amazing
happened it got connected with the rest
of mathematics that often happens in
mathematics when when a problem gets
connected to something else it becomes
accessible actually this felt a prodigy
a pimply 19 year old carl friedrich
gauss in
1796 what he did initially was just to
prove that you could construct a regular
17 gun with ruler and compass and later
on he analyzed the problem completely
and and said exactly what you can
construct i'm going to do the
construction for you that that gauss
proved was possible but if i really do
it with ruler and compass then you'll be
very disappointed because it won't work
and that's just because the little
errors that i make along the way there
are so many little constructions to make
they're all the same and they're all
really easy
but by the time you're finished the
errors have all built up and so i might
construct a 15 gallon
17 gallon there's my circle so i want to
i would like to construct a regular 17
gun in that circle so here goes the
first thing i'm going to do is to draw
a diameter so the next step will be to
construct a perpendicular bisector of
this diameter maybe i'll do one
one such construction just so i'm not
cheating completely i know where one
point is already the center so i don't
have to
draw that here's the other
and i guess i want it to go on for a
while
okay you know i can divide things in
half with ruler and compass so i'm going
to divide them in half and i'm just
going to do it by eyeball we could do it
with ruler and compass but it gets
tedious after a while
and then i want to divide each of these
segments in half two
there's a half and maybe that's a half
like that
and um
then i get to draw another line i'm
going to do that with
the real ruler through the quarter mark
and then i'm going to do something
surprising i'm going to draw a circle
which has this radius this this is half
the length of the radius
this radius and based at that point on
this intersection this this quarter mark
so i'll put a little more ink in there
get it in the hole
and i'll draw this
semi-circle
now i'm going to draw a couple more
lines
this is this construction has a lot of
lines in it but it's really quite easy
do you enjoy this i love it
i love it i don't know why
but it's it's like origami or something
it's very very precise craft stuff
and it does something beautiful
i'm going to draw that line
i'm going to draw this line
and i'm going to divide them both in
quarters 2. so you know i can do that
and i'm going to do it by eyeball again
well you know i could so i want that
quarter and i want this quarter
and i want this one
is that about half
and
this one
all right and now i'm going to draw some
more lines through this point of
intersection and through those two new
points and i'm interested in where they
meet this line down here so there's a
fundamental point that's going to be
useful to me
and here's another
there
okay so now i have these two important
points
on this line
marked and i'm going to draw i'm going
to do something funny i'm going to
bisect this segment from this point to
the edge
it's about here but we'll
maybe i'll do that accurately because
this is important and i'm going to draw
a circle
who's
centered at that midpoint and whose
radius is this so it'll be
inside the circle like that i'm
interested in this point by the way
where my circle meets this line
and i'm going to draw a tiny little
circle
around
the center point with radius this little
distance here
so now i have a another
circle and what i want
is the line
that joins them
there
and now i'm going to draw a circle
which is centered at this funny point
and this radius
so one more circle and we're almost done
we're almost there are you still
enjoying this
i'm getting a little tired of it to tell
you the truth i'm going to draw that
circle
and the crucial thing is where it meets
this line
there
okay
now we are ready
you might say well where's the
where's the 17 gone and i have to
draw out a
perpendicular to this
diameter which meets at that point and
another one here so i'm going to draw a
line here
and a line here and should i eyeball it
or should i do it for real if i'd had a
little more
energy at this point i would use the
compass but what i'm interested in
anyway is this point
and
the corresponding point here
now you might if you're looking really
hard you might say
that's not a 17th of the circle
and in fact it's 2 17 of the circle or
it would be if i had done everything
exactly right
so i have one more division to do
i draw this line
i divide it in half
and i get a point about here
right i would say that's the point
and now
i have my
17th of the circle finally
by drawing this radius
one radius and
2 radius so
this distance
from here to here is supposed to be the
17th of the circle
now
just for fun
and
you may have to
go off camera for this brady let's see
how
close i came all right now i would say i
didn't get quite halfway between because
i estimated that two
three
nine
ten
there's another
and another
oh dear and another
well gee i'm
it seems it's close to a multiple
and the last one what did you make what
have you what gone have you made let's
see so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16
17 18 19
21 so i made a 21 gone by accident an
impossibility so it went wrong because
it's i think probably not even a
numerically stable procedure even if i
had tried to use the compass at every
time and done it as accurately as i
could by the time i made all those
divisions and things little errors would
have built up and it would have come out
wrong one way or another
but
um it's provably the right thing if you
were exactly right
let's see how many doing so this is 1
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15.
here's
and then since it's a 17 gone
maybe it should connect this way
not quite a regular 17-gun but
what can you do
we used to have the address 1000
centennial drive because we we're
actually a small access road gauss way
and centennial drive is the big road
that's nearby
and that was not a problem for us but it
was a big problem for our neighbors our
neighbors are the silver space lab and
they build satellite experiments for
nasa and so these big big trucks would
come rumbling along with some delivery
or to pick up an experiment and there
was no 1 000 centennial drive so they
would rumble right on by and that was a
continual source of of trouble for them
so they finally convinced the university
of california berkeley which is the
person the one who owns the land
to name the access road and they had
some idea that i didn't much like for
naming it after a double star whose
colors were blue and gold
i forget the name of the star actually
and i thought astronomers might know
that but mathematicians won't know it
won't mean anything
so i went to them
actually i said to my colleague maybe we
should name it after
some famous scientist and gauss would be
perfect because he was both a
mathematician and he ran the
the ducal observatory in the town where
he was so he would be honest he was very
important in astronomy actually too
and my colleague at the time said oh you
know you think he was an astronomer but
the astronomers will never have heard of
him and i went over to the director of
the space lab and i said you know i
think we ought to name it after some
famous scientist how about gauss and he
looked at me kind of surprised he said
oh was gauss a mathematician
so
that was a done deal right away
and then they were very generous they
said okay you're you've been nice to us
you can have number one and i said no we
don't want number one we want number 17
because that represents gauss's first
big splash is a mathematician and we're
very much about youth and mathematics
and the success of post-docs and things
like that cultivating young talent
so we got to be 17 gauss way
and on our front doors instead of a
number we put the construction of the
17-gon that i've just showed you